I'll be hot head again no no I changed
her like I don't want to be this color
god dammit disgust dishes so not trendy
you beautiful I know no you're not
I know I'm beautiful you're ugly this is
me this is Ken this is make play has to
okay how about we spice it up and we get
to tweet something from the one who
loses okay fine I'm down whatever I'm
gonna I'm not gonna lose anyway you can
hit those spikes you didn't hit the
spikes oh oh this is the hardest map but
the break oh really oh no no I'm jogging
can we should collaborate against make a
player me on it okay Oh
liber8 against yourself don't grapple me
don't grapple me bro where you going bro
I don't know again don't grab me bro hey
hey oh it's gonna close yeah oh oh this
is better still you can't lose this even
be thanks man
no problem buddy how you gonna handle
the spikes though I'll jump off [ __ ] me
oh [ __ ] later dude okay can let's collab
just fall on app enjoy I don't wanna
tweet play the real game
right yeah
oh why am i winning though hey oh damn
that laughter I'm a good
I mean goof it was industry oh yeah oh
you made it through it make it feel
musky we were supposed to collaborate
[ __ ] every time hope I'm dead now good
meeting you
wait ah ah oh thank you for the double
boosts come on Ken go no oh wait if I
lose who loses what counts is lost only
stain oh crap
that's like Adam I think we we didn't go
through the terms and conditions
properly so if I lose
yeah of course yeah yeah I didn't saw
anything for this job dang it hit
everything mommy did you said you would
intentionally lose right so I mean
that's what your point was what you said
you would intentionally lose everyone
saw it
whoa boozy
what okay okay
hey I just want to talk with you come
back here I just wanted yeah can I can I
just discuss this peacefully with you
please please ah please come no no yeah
yeah if he looks how's that feel how you
staying there
nice you look so handsome and blue oh
come on
no Qingwei yeah being a nice guy and
waiting for we even waiting for you for
a second now for a second I was gone for
a second [ __ ] wait I can win I win I
didn't lose I like to point sudden Liz
oh okay fine what do you want yeah what
do you want us to tweet you can type in
a book i mmm you don't have that much
time
mmm I'm not a Skype anymore yes like on
teamspeak whatever yeah yeah yeah is to
speak see okay if the timer's out you're
not getting anything I'm just saying
that right now
shut up that was in that that was in the
terminal conditions
uh-huh I don't even share this thing his
type down at the bottom to say oh I
don't want it to appear on the stream
coming up the other one the one that
we're actually in the Senate office I
want say in that's all you got it's all
you gotta do I gotta look good uh-oh
that well I mean that's just a fact yeah
see you later
you sons of [ __ ]
you sound some [ __ ] how could you
oh crap OOP why are we doing this
checking map again oh he ran
come on shut your tit why do I do that
extra gel all right oh yes so good lie
like a man for the win
did you call my character is disgusting
oh [ __ ] yeah so I did it's very just hey
guys what's up just fall through the
entire ground yep no room
no thank you no I got one but yeah I got
one yeah do it yeah you do it no you do
yeah then I didn't wanted it all oh yeah
yeah all right
nope nope nope fire goodbye no no yes
I'm already thinking yeah you bound the
spike seriously come on what's up hey
know why me this hikes are the worst oh
come on give me something
well done oh come on hang at the booth
what am i doing take this
got that what's that I get you two I
want you I want you to have the booth
skin it's all party [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
man well I couldn't cannot on them
Oh Oh who's a pious the best I like uh
Oh goddamn this bad this is really bad
who won this who the hell one that
there's no one okay thank God it's gonna
be pissed
yeah come on man key player what do you
what is they what is that you I know
it's great it's my bed
Wow die everybody we how are you still
here what's happening there you can't
let him win you can't I can't go that
easy we'll try not to
don't we rock it oh you don't go for the
boost no you Scoob come on Oh
Oh someone someone not that guy okay
I wrote to you what again this is all
facts drill true haha yes it should be
good well alright then good for you
hi this made winning so much sweeter I
like this idea
yeah are all these tweets just gonna be
but related hey there's no it's not in
the temperature of our and conditions so
you can really do it all yeah I did it
yeah it should all you could see it not
again oh so this isn't the same one it's
sweet no yeah oh oh no you're not gonna
get me a nice grapple bro
best scrapple I ever seen bro
yeah I'm nothing else the highest pitch
I've ever heard you can why this is how
Jesus what is this sucky road oh come on
yeah the neck blare microphone oh no you
all right no thanks what's that magnify
you like drills make a players alright
having too much fun your neighbors
everything Oh No Oh them skills
what's up in mid-air explosions and
stuff so don't go oh well what's up it's
my lilac skin that's all that I credit
or you mean you're disgustingly ugly
probably infected lilac stick how that's
racist feels Bru I'm okay with all all
lilac colors dude Oh Oh what what Oh
rappelled I pitched you like like
drilling you guys like drills or drills
for you scrubs not today ah [ __ ] maybe
today
nope all right we're up not just it's
cute how you guys try so hard even
though you some shut up so much
I got your number now you got my number
what is he don't hit me marry one ball
no you want a grapple bro oh my god what
a grapple yeah yeah she got Scrabble
no wait up a little bit just wait up a
lot yeah boost to kill him this one
that's it okay rigging this up eat back
in [ __ ] back in back in again [ __ ] oh
oh no my controller died I'm at [ __ ]
what yeah wait my controller come on
back for ya wait no you're not we are
castle come on wait
he wouldn't he wouldn't wait for us are
you waiting you're actually ready great
no Aiken what yeah we're for you waiting
for you waiting for
come on come on I can't move it's so
icky
I got ya Bateman I told you I got bug
bites my I got him did Mark oh uh but I
can't move I can't move I can't you move
my controller I had to reset it and we
have to restart the game oh yeah yeah
don't touch my la like body don't you go
near my love my body I wouldn't I
wouldn't dream of it you dad you okay
you guys should just play and then we
start a new one abstractly oh well I'm
going forward with explosions that's
what we'll do because we're nice like
that this is like real life my
controller is non-stop vibrating I guess
you like it this is all do
Fitz look I'm okay never mind that
didn't work I'll push you long you can
do it lick it
wait maybe this is go back stops oh yeah
why do I have this many controllers take
it how do I turn this off okay yeah
bring that off oh yeah oh good wait wait
wait there's a chance of me what are you
doing I'm doing it so hard I'm drilling
them good okay close work
god damn it wait what okay I got you the
wait somewhere where did he go
keeps grand with you me wait I'm a dad
friend battery ok guys you should just
play or whatever what huh
good no ok but I shouldn't have to tweet
because it's not fair yeah let's play
just play dance you're making it so much
more ease oh yeah oh yeah yeah no it's
quality I'm tamanna but you can't get
something back head dance it's not Hey
Oh playing dirty which button is 2-toned
button I know there's a time to get it
right bumper you should try it
it's really good hey Mark yeah it is a
little dad's awesome
yeah the dirty trick
yes it was all padded and playing to
make a play oh no mercy all mercy so
much mercy so much messiness no no how
am I supposed to know that this yeah
please Mac apply it without Mac a plan
he's so happy when he wins I am does a
big fit tomorrow just ward ordinarily my
head's on parson just all your head is
on fire that's the only thing you say Oh
not like hey don't box me why did I
grapple you tomorrow zone for scalp damn
mark you suck hey al box top I don't
like you guys I don't like this game
I don't like anyone I used to win
there's more people watching now it's
not fair damn know no one will know I
didn't get anything because you get
drilling [ __ ] Howie oh oh now you
love this game I bet I'm the best game
in the world right now I'm not winning
yeah oh okay
does it look like a meaning oh yeah eyes
body god oh no it's okay I wanted to go
down here special secrets and all that
how bad rap mass yeah Dave
this part is [ __ ] every part is
[ __ ] this game's okay we both like
soon as you lose you start employment no
I don't know buddy I really don't know
who wants a grapple of jitter huh you
called it
whoa what the [ __ ] oh I'm sorry did you
want something you look no I'm in the
game I'm in the effing game oh you were
gone I am gone when I sing my song huh
Kemba salute
how are you have it okay be nice don't
be nice be dirty
don't be saucy I think my mom is
checking my tweets right now so please
don't
well we're still going into it slowly
really okay so it's mostly please for
those who don't know the one who losers
have to tweet something that the one who
says look my boy gosh con Jude okay
ah okay ah God do it lick it
the whole lick my blade I love that part
so much didi like the best part of the
whole Star Wars rush I get nearly do it
if you eat ready oh I guess we're going
again do this one too yeah ever done
like we've done this already
Rando does not Gus come on you guys have
the host advantage you have the cheating
advantage you have the tricks are tricky
Oh who wants a grapple who wants a what
the [ __ ] no one you guys are so mean
you're mean you're mean normally that's
Tommy you're super nice no no don't lie
mark okay all right you mean then how
dare you lie
who wants a drill you know this drill
did the trick man Jesus it did what what
what yeah okay
wow that's an exchange oh I think I had
the advantage of like head playing this
game last week and you guys are [ __ ]
catching up on Idol cuz we're
professional gamers Oh Oh who's winning
then who was winning then huh no not you
who won the most games huh who wants an
explosion up the butt huh oh really
once again you do that for me I'm not
gonna grab all you cuz you like it so
much
come on oh no way you still have yours
Oh No
yes what what what what what oh wow it's
filled with what one I don't even know
okay oh wait up wait up
Wow Oh marry miss dad hey guys I'm lilac
you have to wait up oh you got it last
place right shut up shut your mouth
winner I shut your damn mouth Chuck you
out oh no no you oh you guys have it I
have issues okay Oh what's up issues
winning [ __ ] so much sighs so that's
fast
you're a completely different person
depending on what place your biggest
true oh damn that's pretty good Wow did
someone want to grapple me because that
shouldn't happen in [ __ ] yes
lilac [ __ ] best scholar but even your
races got my lack you don't know your
color what's it like I don't kind of
like is that is mom that is mom I
guarantee you that's mall that sounds it
really racist I don't like what it looks
purple Vegas scene no no there's a
different David heads up you're not
culturally enough to that's nothing
today we catch any boxes Ken's just a
country bumpkin yay shoes Mississippi
loser doesn't know what Laila Casey
McGehee and we actually now you and I
both are la we guys talk like you know
surfboards no bro are super hipster
which one yeah which one you can say bro
you know rare whatever are you doing
there man you're a tacit rub well brave
totally the control dude it's not going
to bros free again that was bad last
time save that for broforce yeah exactly
that's exactly we did like 10 weeks
oh geez
oh nice bomb brave you can give Omar
bread surprise you crazy bale grapple me
B oh [ __ ] you did it yeah that was
pretty tactical I'd give you that one
thank you thank you
alright well gee Pru I do a double there
you guys don't do a double you guys
double yeah what the hell well you know
I just kind of be you it's gonna happen
like that cuz Oh Prue yeah go hell I
know that actor is coming because you
are so pro so for now okay okay alright
okay okay guys that's okay
alright that's not fun I would be pro if
I had a partnership with razor
I am proud okay Margaret are you shame
art what God diggin let's meet again
you like boxes that is the question I
love your box god no I no no yes oh yeah
yes yeah please okay oh no oh you did a
little dark don't throw me out of my
focus not just give me grout oh shut up
what's that cinema tears King daddies
you really hurt you always get that
you've been practicing timings
practicing because I'm lilac she's
watching speedruns of speedrunners no
wow oh [ __ ] oh that's really bad for me
there's boxes somewhere oh you're dead
now huh no yeah huh wash it locks Monica
I was looking about fire why don't the
banks has never hit you right of the
banks never hit you what is the biggest
never hit you fine I'll uh backfist
Max's burp al that did not help me in
any way come on oh come on big crap I
want to know the least strategy of doing
that on the way down it's really hard to
behind we've almost got out there pretty
hard
shut up oh no please not dumar
money towing no save it for America boy
you guys are against me
you guys are so against me get me you're
so against me oh oh my god oh yeah I
failed
oh Jesus Christ no no you don't have
intent whoa it was good I know it's just
my fingers I really sore from my old
controller yeah you like nope nope yeah
I don't want to tell you guys when we
what you do yeah I don't wait wait I
think your characters are faster - it's
the lilac it looks like Swiss system
barrel and like sir it's the what it's
not very I'd aerodynamic color okay yeah
yeah colors yeah oh these are excuses
are you oh you wouldn't know because
your goddamn Mississippi er ah damn
oh now I get where you said your head
head no no my controller what are you
doing why's you've been racist
oh why it doesn't even move Oh God oh no
no I can't lose no no hi I need to sit
her tweet thanks for supporting that the
charity so far yes thanks for
subscribing Save the Children
subscribing it to join the chat will
also hold the donate that profit will go
to the attorney all everything okay with
the stream will go to the charity and
stuff everything do it for the children
do it for save on 11 lives ago
parodies are awesome your support is
amazing we really approach it I have to
win
I haven't worn
although boxes
wait wait wait oh I know I know why I
couldn't move I had tapped out huh oh my
god what one I didn't see but is he
writing bet I don't I'm not gonna tweet
that that's not okay no no come on boy
why not my but you know what okay fine
why not my but what is wrong with my but
hang on hey Matt sister problem there
you go
hey go hey go I don't see anything which
will also do that better that better
yeah it's not shipping up may do the
second one do the second one with the
second one is this deliver but I get it
is it enough
the thing is there's one more like crap
there's a roulette and stuff wait guys
go let I think these left huh yeah shut
up
ah okay you how do you do this fighter a
duck in its but wait yeah
you're so lucky I went up right away
that's bullish a oh yeah this map has
lasers watch out for the lasers see I'm
not giving me the item Bri Yammer dude
I'm not your brain my brain all right we
used to be based but now in email there
whenever is yeah net Britain is where
thing the heaven we are you supposed to
go here I don't think you're supposed to
oh you're supposed to go I actually went
wrong right right right can of runway
correct job where's that missile come
from grapple something you bought dirty
[ __ ]
you're a dirty slide you're a dirty
little [ __ ] this is real off
what's up in my butt milk play if
daddy's you real name me Nick
or your Union pasty make play oh no am i
oh shut up crap right
oh wait it's Ken what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah wait up you scrub wait up Wow
Wow
you don't even wait don't talk to me
anymore everyone oh wait because I would
have waited no wood how do you know I
was telling last game and you're like
heck yeah get in here Nikki pain no
Megan do it make me Oh laser people it's
on my side that's why I have this that's
enough [ __ ] oh whoa thanks for now come
on what are you doing Nick hey man hey
what are you doing Oh God not this part
Oh
what's that make okay
don't you demo no man to zero what's up
me who that laser almost got us okay
oh it's it yeah knock crapple huh hey
hey I'm gonna have to censor the stream
now god damn it you can't say crap oh
yeah I win no he won oh come on yeah
yeah I still gotta tweet the other one
that didn't get to before the game
started meet see ya I don't want to
tweet none of our [ __ ]
treat something what is your idea your
idea yeah what's your idea why do you
always have to play me cuz it's your
fault alright did you write anything you
don't have that much time brave there
you go copy paste no I'm not no no no oh
right there
I'm open up oh yeah okay you know what
I'm just gonna say okay fine but you you
going down next time okay oh it's you
geez yeah bring it on now there people
are gonna
again made from the my Twitter's Hector
son of our words
Oh God I'm deleting I'm deleting that
one right after this round me too god
damn
but whatever you are you big [ __ ]
how great who want to hit those facts
over they uh not Ali not me Oh No good
back then we're glad you got the item
there I got it in in guess really need
boxes what up runway oh why don't you
grab a burger
make it a Morgan why did you come over
here make a big would you say kitten why
play leo say so as ken doesn't win but
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh those spikes are deadly man yeah
what are you going to do it yeah Rick
sucks trihard him so hard Jesus Jia's
become a chicken or some [ __ ] do we make
a bomb now make the way I'm letting this
body flailing through brings me such joy
we oh I took care of those for you well
your was good
you want your mom you're welcome you all
do it negatively mark okay we're going
good oh come on Timmy toes can lift up
Gabe hey uh I don't know that I'm just
unscrew that oh no no you come on
yeah I'm gonna beat him for us Freddy
the vert for pity I know what it was
everyone's one true OTP be the best in
situ in room just I've kept listening is
my cause come on
ah ah ah come on come on Oh God
okay let me read that do you have a cool
guy
what are you doing wrapping that way my
life your heads on fire
oh you're a totem gotta I'll give you
like a piece of gum if you can let me
win oh is it winter fresh what he won
what the [ __ ]
yes so good he'll win lose your being
behind ha ha ha best game ever
speaking best game im just bamboozled oh
[ __ ] oh god damn oh jeez
all right what Ken that's cheating
what's cheating low unless you die in
what it's totally yeah it's not gonna
make it
okay all right if I saw that's too cool
for school look at me that nice you man
my net that school is cool I totally had
that one that's [ __ ] what happened
uh I hate this game
Jenny yeah no you can't like slide on
the ground yeah you slide on the ground
use you or light in midair when they're
jumping as well huh I didn't know this
something like that
wait what ha that's you what's up
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is up did you hit the
spot is not even a good shortcut like
why do I even do that
now ken is gonna win I don't want to
lose again I don't want to tweet anymore
nonsense
hey no check it check it you I'm not
checking anything yo check it yo bro J
[ __ ] I'm la Street now oh that's pretty
check it weapon I think he grabbed your
butt and it was oh that's pretty good
Mike you play it thank you
I'm Vinny play children it's about doing
other things for the job do cat where as
you give your bull crap winner
[ __ ] hell son of a [ __ ] Maddy Maddy
okay
all right I'm telling it we sold a pinky
food meekly hey Katy beefy he's gonna be
saying that the whole stream just making
me yes okay
oh no he's leading and he has a grapple
[ __ ]
yes I went the wrong way though whoa
yeah a lot ago that grapple does he over
there watch out for the spikes mega
player dad it was very close thank you
you didn't go oh okay I gotta let you
win my complaint yeah oh yeah you gonna
let me win yeah we gonna let him win
thank you God you are the best now if I
just don't hit the spike up here you're
flying no actually I'm not risking this
I'm not risking this mano you got this
now we're letting you in and I gotta get
a [ __ ] tweet for my thing delete the
last week yes yeah you might be so it to
delete oh god it got 195 retweets Jesus
okay and Ken you have to tweet yeah
let's you love bow for butts
well you didn't win mark did well I let
him win so I get obeying any oh sure
it's his stream you know you're gonna
listen to him like you know you're
totally right and you got it right time
anywhere right tell me we'll go by Mark
quick quick quick
what somebody oh uh but that's what I'm
put it that's it - gate really do do it
oh Jesus he does say blargh how long are
we gonna play this day however the hole
needs you Hey could be a
winner-takes-all round or something for
like we're gonna be pros at this game by
the end of it I mean I am already a pro
bro I mean X little G baby this is my go
to Matt what okay okay alright alright
all right are you listening to Kevin
Hart Oh half am now that's not Kevin
Hart turn down for what
No turn down for that [ __ ] aah oh my
god
Oh [ __ ] hell why is life so difficult
now will it make a player catch it
how could this happen to me misty I
really did a cover of that song today
did you watch it yeah what it's not up
yet
but I feel like you've watched me or
something I literally filmed it right
before the stream oh you did yeah Oh
something I always do
oh really we're problem man oh no I
little admitted Joe Caroline crap oh
yeah there you should rule away from the
blood sheets hey what happened to your
uh shuttle there shut up heard pear
my name is not pewdiepie it's Felix I'm
a person okay
put a pair and I'm losing pretty hard
right nice missile shot you're yeah oh
I'm good
get back Oh didn't work Oh actually
caught up son of a son of a son of a
something son of a make it pay goddamn
it huh good good I don't have it today
so you guys are hosting so yeah yeah
look whatever really good at this game
like I'm telling you you're two-faced
every time I'm telling you I'm telling
you why like you're waiting here like
I'm so good and if you lose you guys
you're a two-faced [ __ ] okay so don't
you dare talk to me like that
yeah was it I where's there okay you're
not winning right now and I went there
Yuwen tuo what that [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
this game is the best okay what does
best game ever I'm letting worst games
what the [ __ ] are you Mark said Oh No
oh pretty good my uh maybe one day no
maybe one day I don't need us did you
confuse yourself with the greatness of
the first dragon ball head man Oh God uh
if you like reference no you're like I'm
a communist dirty commie mega player I
tragedy everyone I'm dead I killed
myself cuz I thought I was Ken for a
second I just had yeah make it kill it
so he's like my kid another worth it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh stop touching my butt
no Kenny I know what you're thinking I
dodged that [ __ ] I oh oh that's pretty
good I hate to do that how did you do
that I don't want to saw you do it
earlier back student oh yeah oh Jesus
whatever something on the Jimmy I'm a
snow possible what are you doing here
you missed I was waiting to shoot at me
but sucking [ __ ] so the momentum will
be back for Oh get all those boxes
you're a momentum upper but mom animal I
memento your but no hello hello what's
up Ken what's your name Oh what's your
name Ken what's your name tell me
everything I want to know every detail
every detail ever no no make plan
Macca plan were megabyte I don't know if
you guys saw what I saw but why switchin
what though I want to I want to send out
a tweet please guys please
oh you guys are doing that now okay I
see yeah it's called skills good with it
uh brisk
can you read it a little bit revs nope
nope nope ah
marks Lonnie can you're lying
No okay I can't Bob you don't grab a
booth that gave me speed thanks
appreciate it
neck pain
wait oh no oh no it's come on give me
something good no no don't don't I would
walk - I know you were gonna do that
yeah fellas gonna grapple and be going
faster but I didn't who uh-huh you did
it better and Weiss up I'm lilac and you
like it yeah do more
Oh God my mom was like mama I was purple
and don't you yet yeah
what oh yeah no not okay with that Ken
had a bet that has to be professional in
your titties oh that gave me speed thank
you it has to be precaution in your
titties don't read into what I'm saying
well you're not supposed to repeat it
makes me look bang hmm make it a go down
make it black hi I had a great bill
what's up sing my song all night long
Mick play make a page view it may I say
it was a [ __ ] a treat call baby yes
on your gravestone ill replay at ease mr
k 3p l DX Y Q Duke that's a great way to
spell it it's my favorite way to spell
it there's a lot of ways to spell it but
that's Micro God that Brian Regan
jugular that like beer a lot American I
don't Brian Regan brother good take you
here with you well I'm American no wait
you are late hello beautiful you never
listen to Brian Regan do you know what a
Brian Regan is you Ricky delicious I
know Ricky Martin Jackie O
gg-go Ricky Martin is kind of close to
Brian Regan really Brian Regan like in
all seriousness Brian Regan is one
these comedians like one of my favorite
okay he's Hall arson if you've never
seen him your infantry I'm sure I seen
him I just don't know the names of a lot
of comedians I've seen oh okay is he
British no no use American kappa no i
don't know americans don't have that
grapple t-handle do that am i gonna do
it or am I good you're getting to the
wall hmm I hit you through the wall
[ __ ]
I think the leg is helping you I think
the lag is a lag camera I'm not I should
just stop talking
Wow you guys want to animate it I do
thanks you're welcome it rot it
no biggie every time I swear to God
come on my missing two dogs are modest
really intense gaming the end of your
nose isn't my nose tingles tense whoa
what was that a pun yeah no no I didn't
say anything
baby no guy
come baby Mack a flag those mean again
please do that again many more times
appreciate it really
oh why do I grapple nothingness this is
my life I'm glitching off you all your
likes glitching not even really
glitching that's cuz he's got that
British lag going in itself and oh no
I'm up here lucky do you again oh oh no
I'm in the game
you're taunting for no reason I can't
even see you
what am i guess [ __ ]
is not using them alright yeah she works
with Ken's
[ __ ] King doesn't believe Zi long Oh
sign up for speedrunners yet no no I won
this game of course
prepare for tweeting out the best food
ever is it alright how do I do that to
myself I guess you just do it I don't
know right
no it's vice-versa so make a right oh
that's just for Ken yeah yeah you write
that one right your your replace make a
player with oh nice time to go okay
let's wait that's all it's all the way
doubt that's all right I will wait no no
I gotta look at let's all wait up roar
as fast you can
what I was making play with me oh let's
scrub welcome welcome
get over here [ __ ] you need it I
probably need it okay alright okay
well me baby thank you
Wow why are you still here you [ __ ]
what cuz I'm tenacious and I what why
you guys working together to thwart my
you guys that want to write my tweets
just no one likes you
nope well that's pretty harsh okay I
like you I mean it's true but I mean I
didn't know you had feelings hurt don't
robot that has to hurt what are you
doing I don't know who do you think you
are moving shaking screwed all I like
it's been securely screen why are we
here
screw that I'm talking I'll deal with it
I laid it wrap your now wake him all
right you should just let me win come on
no wedding here you let it win I will
give you my [ __ ]
what yeah like a penny now that's too
much I guess I can't across amazing
shiny thing oh sorry no we'll be buying
it it's like the worst one ever
haha make it long jump in yet I let him
win you know make it but I lose if any
later look I'll be that in Coloma you're
gonna have to earn it
what am i doing out here oh no oh no I
made it no job I didn't make it make it
pay yes hey how much it'll be good don't
do it name Ebru I don't have to be we do
Oh
do it OOP there give you your beauty you
really better be with him when he goes
through there you can be screwed and I'm
gonna take the shortcut cuz I'm that
good okay you just grab any scrap all
right that said for the speed orders
final tweet yes
do it